le choix des candidats pour l'élection
est presque terminé et vous allez voir
que dans l'ouest du pays
le npd est confronté un problème assez
inusité rémi gauthier à tous les détails
dans deux provinces voisines deux
candidats portent le même nom
le nez d'infirmières et médecine hat
dans le sud de l'alberta
l'autre est économiste d'origine en
saskatchewan les deux sont candidats au
nouveau parti démocratique et tous les
deux se nomme erin weir pour le candidat
d'origine à la situation est plutôt
cocasse c'est peut-être une opportunité
de améliorer la représentation des tous
les gens qui se prennent bel ornement de
sexe
il dit avoir été contacté par son
homonyme de l'alberta avant qu'elle ne
devienne candidate de long même étudier
la possibilité de produire des pancartes
électorales commune
une idée qui a finalement été abandonnée
cette situation ne crie pas de confusion
dans la tête des électeurs croit le
candidat d'origine parce qu'ils ne sont
pas dans la même circonscription ni dans
la même province
avoir une photo des candidats sur les
bulletins de vote ne changera donc pas
grand chose selon lui mais avant nommé
non plus causé des problèmes
administratifs
quelquefois ça arrive que je reçois au
genou quelquefois et le second courriel
pour moi à se prendre un problème mais
ça arrive il ya un peu de confusion
ça ne risque pas de poser de problème
non plus si les deux erin weir santé lui
c'est qu'à la chambre des communes les
députés ne sont pas désignés par leurs
noms ont par leur circonscription et ça
il n'y en a pas deux pareils